comment est né par exemple une de vos
chansons qui manque de chance ou bien
champagne quoi comment ces chansons sont
nées elles ont une histoire tout d'un
coup dans un monde imaginaire c'est venu
en marchant c'est qu'est ce qui s'est
passé non moi c'est souvent la musique
qui est donc la structure de la musique
et du rythme qui me kim qui m'inspire
les paroles c'est assez rare que soient
les paroles sur lequel j'écris de la
musique maintenant oui pratiquement
c'est toujours la musique et après la
musique c'est comme si je planter un
décor une émotion et dans cette émotion
je commence à voir des images des choses
qui se passent des visions des choses
que j'ai vécues et aussi parfois des
choses que j'imagine comme conteur pas
comment je vais raconter une histoire
des fois c'est juste un thème et souvent
c'est parfois juste une phrase qui
démarre st et puis de cette phrase là ça
nous arrive moi je démarre d'un endroit
et samarie de longtemps après de finir
une chanson est plus être du tout à
l'endroit où j'étais au début c'est à
dire c'est que les mômes ont entraîné
bien au-delà de ce que je pouvais
imaginer et s'est passé un voyage d'un
voyage et puis moi je sais pas je m'en
retourne et à nous je vois aussi raymond
devos comme un jongleur parce qu'à un
moment donné tout à l'heure le sens
dessus dessous
c'est un numéro de jonglage
extraordinaire avec des phrases que tout
le monde connaît l'histoire
vous avez ainsi que ce point en commun
d'ailleurs je viens d'avoir des trains
peu commedia dell'arte je me suis à du
spectacle que vous aviez fait y ait une
dizaine d'années au palais du cirque
d'hiver ouais t'es des merveilleuses
choses vous descendiez si même le marais
bonne sur un piano blanc des cintres
quelque chose comme ça avec d'ailleurs
toute une gymnastique extraordinairement
sûr
j'adore c'est vrai ça devrait fait
voyager comme ça m'a fait voyager le
piano était en bas le couvercle monter
moi là-bas que j'en ai plus pour mon
compte chacun kosovo mais c'est bien
parce que je trouve que c'est ça le
spectacle aussi mais je sais par exemple
mais plus maintenant avec souvent non
j'ai parlé à ce oui ce que je veux dire
simplement ceci c'est plus on parle de
création là comment ça démarre toi tu
viens de parler de votre en plein
montant des buts intitulé une émotion ça
te fais pas tu penses un chemin pourquoi
à partir de ce chemin c'est un peu
facile départ mais tu fais tu pars tu
pars à l'aventuré car il faut tout de
même dire que l'invention ses aventures
on part à l'aventuré
c'est comme ça que j'ai mangé âgées un
choc de départ et puis ça s'emballe et
puis je ne sais pas mais je pressens je
dis ça ça mène quelque part et puis bon
c'est en cours de route je m'aperçois
que j'arrête mais en général je me
trompe pas il ya une phrase de jacques
gironde par instinct aussi parce que
comme il le dit justement c'est comme un
voyage et un moment donné sur cette
route là c'est une route effectivement
c'est un voyage bourré routes aériennes
et souterraines
ian fry quand on l'apprend on peut
découvrir d'autres choses et moi j'adore
ça par contre j'aime pas être sûr de là
où je vais j'aime pas du tout ça
[Musique]